hello
[Applause]
i don't know what to talk to you about
first
okay i guess let's start with the high
school musical
class of 2020 homeschool musical
lin-manuel miranda is already also like
i'm watching i'm loving
hbo max bought it and really let's face
it it's hbo
max and netflix or the two big kahunas
in the game right now as far as
the way everybody really watches
everything especially in 2020.
so these are the big leagues and they're
all acknowledging how
important and incredible this project is
that you started
what gave you the impetus an idea you
were stuck at home
it was coved and you
i was living with my mom my husband
and my daughter and i we went home to
new jersey to quarantine
with my parents instead of being in our
tiny new york city apartment
um and my mom who's an incredible voice
teacher
she was crying um and i was like what's
going on you know obviously the world
was exploding and she said i'm just so
disappointed for my students they've put
so much
time and effort into these shows and now
their shows are all cancelled
and for me drew it it wasn't even about
like everyone needs to be able to do
their musical
like this is a generation of kids that
self-identifies as anxious
more than any previous generation and i
know that's a really big deal
and i know for me i always felt other
except for the one weekend a year where
i got to do my musical
and when my town was like oh she's not
just weird she's talented
okay and i felt seen and
i felt i was brokenhearted for these
kids
that not only were they not going to be
seen by their communities they were
gonna disappear
into quarantine and i just didn't want
them to feel like they were ghosts
well not only did you do that but i mean
hbo max made a special out of it you had
so many responses you put this out into
the world with a very raw
sort of call to action uh post that you
did
and the response was overwhelming and
there are a lot of people
who want to be seen and what you've done
with this is such a big deal it's become
such a big movement
so celebrated so acknowledged and this
now comes out december 17th am i correct
on that date
yes good okay yeah and i just think that
you've done something that's so
meaningful and i really believe this is
going to continue
to be one of many because this is the
world we're living in and let's face it
this is not
all going to transition immediately
we've still got a ways to go
hope is on the way but i think we also
have learned
that this new alternative that we've all
been forced into may not be so bad
maybe it's like social media and the web
itself it can bring
all these people together from all over
the world
and i think you ignited a spark that's
going to turn into
the right kind of brush fire um
and i just think that your intention
and the way you did it and it's so great
that you saw your mom
you know going through that and i know
you wanted to be a
like a performer when you were young and
both your parents are in theater and
they're like no we want to keep you a
kid you have to wait
so you got into high school musicals
and did all of that yeah yeah my mom
and dad were theater performers and then
um
when i was like two years old my parents
got divorced i'm fine
and um my mom remarried my dad sal
who's a psychotherapist and a health
counselor and so i grew up
in new jersey in like a really normal
environment
and even though i begged my parents to
please let me be an actress
they were like no so i'm the same way
with my kids too i'm like when you're
old enough to cope and know yourself
you know because i come from an
experience that's very
abnormal and i loved it but it's it's i
just want my kids to have a head on
their shoulder
that feels stable so i get it but i'm
glad that you found your way
i love you as melania trump on colbert
oh my god you are
so funny and we both played julia
ghoulia
yes we both i did it and we did we did
it on broadway we have
such a great connection we do we do but
look at that wig that is just a wig that
made me
at 26 look like a 50 year old helen hunt
it's not a great wig i don't know what
they did
well you don't know what happened laura
can we do will you come back on the show
we can get on the green screen and do
the two julia's together
honestly you were so brilliant and
iconic in that part like
no one else should ever play it ever i
disagree and i'd like to do it with you
and i'll do it i'll do it for you i love
your children's book
m is for mama and also merlot i'm
telling you run and get this book it is
so good for parents
so fun so special so unique as are you
when i did my research on you i was just
like i want to talk to you about you as
a human being you're such an interesting
person with such a
unique profound outlook on life and i
have such deep respect for you so
please let this be the first of many
like gatherings that we do together
but i really want to focus on the
subject at hand
this homeschool musical class of 2020
and i understand you may have something
i'm hearing this in my ear is this true
i do i have a little gift from the kids
of homeschool musical class of 2020 for
you and for cake week
what oh yeah what
yeah okay happy cake week to
you happy cake week to
you happy cake week drew
barrymore
happy cake week to you
that's really good
thank you thank you laura benanti
homeschool musical class of 2020 is
available
on hbo max december 17th and her
self-titled debut album laura benanti
which has such an interesting history
where it spans the generations of music
and genres is please come back and let's
talk about that let's talk about
everything
and do julia's